[Applause]
from the tennis courts of compton to the
war-torn streets of belfast and a
colombian village
from a universal road of addiction and
recovery to the elite realm of
international espionage
those compositions these compositions
took us on deeply human journeys around
the world
their powerful and engaging lyrical
motifs combined with dynamic
instrumental storytelling touched our
souls
each piece created an emotional
experience that will remain with us long
after the final credits here are the
nominees for original song
be alive from king richard music and
lyric by dixon and beyonce knows harder
[Music]
[Music]
down to joy from belfast music and lyric
by van morrison
[Music]
no time to die from no time to die music
and lyric by billy eilish and phineas
o'connell
somehow you do from four good days music
and lyric by diane warren
somehow you do
and the oscar goes to
[Applause]
billy eilis
this is the first oscar and nomination
for the brother and sister team of billy
eilish and phineas o'connell
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
whoa
oh my god
[Applause]
you guys oh my gosh um
this is so wonderful people could scream
um thank you to our double-oh-seven
family barbara broccoli marco g wilson
mgm kerry fukunaga daniel craig to han
zimmer who's not here but is so amazing
steven lipson johnny marr for for taking
our song and making it worthy of james
bond
our managers danny brandon and laura we
love you so much
[Applause]
and thank you to tony styler we love you
lastly we want to thank our parents who
um have always been our biggest
inspirations and our heroes and we love
you as parents and we love you as real
people too
thank you so much to the academy we
promised not to lose these
[Applause]
you